let's go welcome to my channel
oh for the love of christ
what are the healthiest nuts to eat
matthew mcconaughey's
advertising my cashews all right
snapchat sunglass filter yeah okay those
look fake
listen i don't think those masks in the
background are for
any type of athletic event yeah that's
four masks you know they're swinging
they are swinging in that house oh yes
they absolutely are
oh my goodness all right rip it
yeah all right all right all right
yes the first three words this young man
ever
said on film thank you
uh yes mcconaughey here and i want to
welcome you to my youtube channel it's a
destination
where i'm going to share who i am who
i'm not what i believe in what i don't
what i'm doing what i'm not doing along
with some approaches to life that i've
found useful and constructive along the
way
uh prescriptions in the art of living
that have helped me navigate this rodeo
we all live in
and even a bunch of bumper stickers that
i've seen heard gathered and stolen a
long way over my last 51 years here
hopefully it's gonna be all killer no
phillip with some wraps and rhymes that
can help you get back on time put a
little reason to your rhyme
some food for thought with a sip of wine
bring your funny bone don't be afraid to
bend a knee and join me in the chase to
be
more me with your chase to be more you
what else are we really here to do don't
forget to subscribe to my channel and
click the notification bell to be
notified when i post a new video
check out everything someone said i'm
going to be working on i am looking
forward to connecting with you
so in the
[Laughter]
some meantime taking her phone and
putting it right into her [ __ ] finger
it
touch it touch it matthew
do the whistle do the whistle on my way
you are who who you're not
in your journey to be to become more
youth
tell me who i am tell me who i am i'm
just gonna be like
16 year old tick tock comments why did i
lick the screen bro why did you stop
all i can taste is my screen
what a ridiculous um intro to youtube
though
yeah that's a i mean that could not be
more him
right all right all right all right all
right all right
a little rhythm to your rhyme a little
similar sign with a glass of wine what
are you what
what are we talking about here you're
just gonna are you vlogging is this your
intro to vlogging
a little rhyme to your video
a little rhythm to your whoa kenny
a lot of rhythm to yet whoa kenny
wine on time
a little rhythm to you jungle beats
holla at him
oh my god ronnie
yeah i don't know man i mean to me i
actually think he's he's playing himself
a little bit i think he's gonna be a
little too much
what do you mean i i think people are
gonna get over it
i feel like part of the con was it was
like you know
you had to go seek it out you had to go
watch a movie
you know even even with a book you know
you got to go by you got to read it
now he's just cheapening his [ __ ] i mean
give it three months
he'll be on twitch there was no way
before
for us to learn about who he is who he's
not what he's doing
and what he's not doing that's the part
that's the part that's crazy to me
what hey y'all just making a little
video to let you know
i am not eating meat this week
i'm not not [ __ ] tens constantly
but i will be having a little roast beef
you catch my drift in my lift
now when i talk um
this dude is just rhyming every other
two sentences
no but here's the thing like yeah this
is the thing with a-list celebs on
youtube like when will smith first came
on youtube remember i was like i'm a big
fan of his channel it's crazy
like such high production value and all
and then like his videos were getting
like millions of views right off the bat
and his channel was
remember that he came on he was getting
like a hundred thousand subs a day just
yeah
killing it videos were like really good
and then it's like they just totally
taper off like
they don't they almost stop caring it
just becomes like a uh
promotion vehicle almost yeah for them
yeah not to say i don't know i haven't
watched a will smith video in forever
but i'm still sub doom i still see them
pop up and it's like they're way
less popular let's just wondering if
like dude if matthew mcconaughey did it
one video a week where
it was just him sitting in that office
you know
talking about whatever's on his mind i
bet he would kill it
you think doing commentary yeah if you
did like a podcast or something
he's good in that medium i mean you know
will had a banger a couple months ago
but yeah you know his videos are how
many views
uh 3.1 i mean then he then he had the
whole
he got some views here off of his um
entanglement meme
oh oh right that was rough yeah
right that's rough you don't want to see
will down like that
yeah that was a rough one that was
yeah you know that was five months ago
really five or six months ago it was a
half a [ __ ] year ago
yeah this time last year we were stuck
inside it was like the first lockdown
it's crazy and here we are a year later
still inside still inside well no i mean
we're part we haven't been in the studio
because you know
okay just we got something yeah we
wouldn't be we we would be we don't want
to we got
something just shut the [ __ ] up and
don't ask no dumbass
questions all right uh shut up all right
just keep shut up if you don't think
we're making moves
here's if you don't think we're making
moves right now
[Laughter]
here's the thing real bosses move in
silence
all right i don't know if you've ever
heard that before
but that's a that's real don't talk
like i'm trying to do is [ __ ]
you can pick up because here's the thing
i feel like that's he's always just
trying to ram words together
hold on can you pull up the tick tock
loop yeah let's let's get gary vee
getting
head let's this [ __ ] is so good man
[Laughter]
are you on tick-tock
i can't even do it the way he did him
it's so good
[ __ ] good i love blueberries not
bluebells yeah what's your name
lisa you keep talking about ideas on how
to get me out faster
but ideas are [ __ ] until you execute
them okay you think you're bad who
[ __ ] cares
i love losing i recommend [ __ ] up on
purpose
how old are you 24. like you have so
much time to eat [ __ ]
and suck balls you're scared of other
people's opinions [ __ ] your parents
stop trying to take your dicks and
instead suck mine okay
full speed macro
[Laughter]
are you on tink talk
yeah what did he say micro speed macro
patience micro speed macro patience
[Music]
okay yeah i like blueberries not blue
balls all right
you keep you keep talking about how to
get me off faster
but ideas are [ __ ] until you execute
are you on tick-tock
you